-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actress
you know from
"Friday Night Lights,"
"Nashville," and "Dirty John."
She stars in
the critically acclaimed show
"The White Lotus."
The first full season
is streaming on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Just lift it.
-Push it. Tilt.
Oh, oh.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
-Ohh.
-Oh, God.
-Are you okay, Paula?
-No.
-Alright,
I'm gonna start my Zoom,
and, you guys, if you're
gonna stay in here,
you have to be totally silent.
Okay?
And stay out of the frame.
-Mom, you look deranged.
-It's alright.
I have a filter for that.
Oh [bleep]
-Please welcome back to the show
Connie Britton.
How are you, Connie?
-Hi, Seth.
I'm so good.
How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
Congratulations for being in
the show of the summer,
the most talked-about show
of the summer.
It must be exciting because,
you know, I feel like I --
You know, I'm such a fan of your
work on "Friday Night Lights,"
which I feel like is a show that
people just kind of discovered
maybe a little bit
after the fact.
It must be so fun
to be in something
that everybody is watching
in real time.
-It is.
It's a fascinating experience
because, you know,
particularly in the world now,
we're all bingers now
and it's all --
you know, it's all --
There's so much conversation
around the shows,
the shows of the season,
the shows of the season.
And to be --
Now I'm the conversation.
We're the conversation,
"The White Lotus."
I mean, honestly,
it's really Mike White.
Mike White is the brilliant
creator of "The White Lotus."
And this is all his brainchild.
We're just like little pawns,
little robots
in his crazy, crazy world.
But it's fascinating
to think about
what it is that hits
the zeitgeist.
You know, like, why are people
so interested in this show?
You know, I mean, like,
what do you like about it, Seth?
I think it just hits home
in a way where it makes it okay
for people to see themselves
in a not-very-nice light.
-Well, there's a lot of --
It ticks a lot of boxes for me.
Let's just start with,
in today's world,
where things move really fast,
if you give me a six-episode
season, I'm super psyched.
Right off the bat, I know I'm
gonna have the time for it.
I mean, for people
who haven't watched,
I'm not giving anything away.
The first five minutes
of the show,
they basically tell you that
someone dies at this resort.
So there now you got me
on the hook.
And, you know,
the cast is so fantastic.
But you are right --
Like, there's this singular
Mike White writing style
that complete--
reveals itself immediately.
And it is just so much fun
to watch you all
play around with those scripts.
-And, you know, I think, like,
right now in the culture,
there's so much conversation
going on.
We really are assessing
ourselves as a culture,
as you know, because you're
at the forefront of that.
And so to be able to do that
in a satirical way
where it takes --
We can clearly look
at these characters
and see that they are,
for the most part, hideous.
And yet -- And so we can freely,
you know, look at ourselves
because we have to be better
than they are.
And yet -- And we can laugh,
and, you know,
that's a really good way
to make a little commentary
about what's happening
in the world.
-Hideous people in pretty
fantastic surroundings.
You got to shoot this
at the Four Seasons in Maui
in the middle of a pandemic.
This strikes me as maybe
the best possible place
to go to work.
-You know what?
I have to agree with you.
-Yeah.
-The Four Seasons --
I mean, Maui is the best
possible place to go to work
and particularly
in the middle of a pandemic.
I was already -- You know, I'm
such a huge fan of Mike White's.
I was already on board,
you know, minute one.
But then he said,
"We're shooting in Maui."
And I said,
"Oh, you're so brilliant.
You're more brilliant
than I even thought you were.
Yes, I will come,
happily and gladly."
And then we got there,
and it's like "Ahhh!"
You know, we'd all been
in quarantine
for however many months.
And it's so beautiful
and magical,
and we had the whole hotel
to ourselves for a while,
and that was really amazing.
And then we realized
we couldn't leave.
-Yeah.
-It was weird.
And I was like, "COVID,
you're making this weird.
How are you making Maui
weird for us?
What is that about?"
And it's like,
"I can't go to the waterfall
if I have a day off?"
"No, no, you can't go to
the waterfall on the day off."
And so then it became
this really hilarious thing
where we were sort of like,
"We're in the most beautiful
place in the world,"
and also, "I want to go
to the waterfall,"
and then, "Am I becoming
the actual character
that I'm playing?"
It became very meta.
It was very like,
what's happening?
Who am I?
-Who would want
to hear you complain
about being trapped in Maui,
at the Four Seasons in Maui,
no less?
-Right, right.
Turns out nobody. Nobody.
-You play the mother
of teenagers,
who are mortified by everything
you do on the show.
I believe your son is 10 now.
Is that an age where --
Is he capable of being mortified
by you yet?
-He's not there yet,
thank goodness.
10 is a really cute, good age.
But I will tell you --
Here's what they don't tell you
about where that sort of
mortification comes from,
and the answer is, particularly
during a pandemic, television,
specifically the Disney Channel.
-No!
-Oh, yeah.
Seth, there are shows
on the Disney Channel --
Like, they're always
called people's names,
like "Jessie" or "Ricky --
Ricky, Dicky, & Dawn."
And there might be another one
in there, too.
-Okay.
-And these are like --
They are these shows that, like,
the kids love,
for whatever reason.
Eyob will watch them on a loop.
The same --
And I said, "Are you watching
that show again?"
And he's like, "Yeah, I mean, I
already watched the full season.
So I'm just rewatching it."
But the thing is,
then he starts, you know,
when we're talking,
he starts talking to me
in these kind of quippy ways
that I can tell
he's now emulating
Disney Channel characters.
And I'm like,
"This is the beginning.
This is the beginning
of him being --"
-This is on you,
Ricky, Dicky, and Dawn.
-This is on you, Ricky, Dicky,
and Dawn, and Mickey Mouse.
-Real quick before we go,
you worked with one of
my favorite people in the world,
Jennifer Coolidge.
And it just must have
been a dream.
-Jennifer Coolidge
is a national treasure,
and I'm so glad that we now can
all just acknowledge that fully
when we see her brilliant work
in this show.
And I'm obsessed with her,
and I was recently down
in New Orleans.
And she has a house
in New Orleans
and she invited me over.
And I was like,
"There's no way I'm missing
going to Jennifer Coolidge's
house in New Orleans."
And I was sort of doing
other things all day.
And she texted me.
She goes, "You have to --
No matter what, even if
it's late, you have to come
because I feel like the spirits
are really strong tonight."
And I was like, "You are right,
Jennifer Coolidge.
Of course I have to come
if the spirits are really strong
at your house."
So I went to her house,
and she has the most
unbelievably gorgeous house
in New Orleans.
I mean, it feels like
it's like a full city block.
And so I get there
and I'm waiting at the gate
and I text her
and I'm like, "I'm here."
And I think
a full five minutes passed,
and then she finally
texted me back,
and she's like, "Oh, great!"
And then another
five minutes passed
when she finally came out
to the gate to let me in,
because there was no way
actually in
and there was a big,
brooding gate.
And so then I walked into
the house, and everything --
There is no electrical light on.
It is all candlelight.
And it is the most beautiful,
perfectly, perfectly decorated
Victorian house,
completely candlelit.
I mean, the candelabras
were candlelit.
Everything was candlelight.
And it was like walking into
a house from like the 1800s
but also a haunted house.
Like, I couldn't decide
what the vibe was.
And then her dining room table
had all these wine bottles on it
and she was like,
"Do you want wine?"
And I'm like,
"Of course I want wine."
And she goes,
"And we have pizza."
And so we went back
to her back terrace
and ate pizza and drank wine
until 1:00 in the morning
waiting for the spirits
to show up,
which they didn't quite do,
but it really didn't matter,
because I got to, like,
be at Jennifer Coolidge's
amazing house.
-Maybe she was the spirit
the whole time.
-She is the spirit.
She's a good spirit.
-She is the spirit, and that's
the answer to the question, yes.
-Congratulations so much
on the show.
It's always so lovely
to see you,
and hopefully next time
you can be here in person.
-I know. I can't wait.
I really can't wait for that.
Thanks, Seth.
-The full first season
of "The White Lotus"
is streaming on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."